bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
notre édition le réseau du cri célèbre
les 20 ans d'yves live son dispositif
d'accompagnement artistique
à cette occasion quatre concerts sont
organisés nous en parlons dans quelques
instants avec nos invités à partir de
janvier la maison de la poésie donne
carte blanche à péret mist català pour
six soirées musique et poésie nicolas
gervais nouvelle tous les détails avec
welcome abord déclic théâtre agit contre
les discriminations retour sur ce
spectacle une fiche et idées reçues
provoc mais surtout ont pour but
d'éveiller les consciences
chaque semaine le septième art est mise
à l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphiles galles pino responsable du
grenier à sel à trappes livrera son coup
de coeur pas moins de 132 groupe et six
cent soixante musiciens ou et
accompagner dans le développement de
leur carrière artistique
pourtant ce sont tous des artistes
yvelinois grâce au dispositif yves live
alors créé par le son de ressources
illinois pour la musique plus
communément appelé le cri yves live fête
cette année ses 20 ans bonsoir ciré
duval vous êtes donc le directeur du cri
vous allez nous parler de ce dispositif
et puis vous êtes venu accompagné de
jean pierre lautier bon soin de soi
alors on vous appelle dans le métier j p
donc je le ferai aussi va être césar
alors vous vous êtes le programmateur du
café de la plage à mort par vous allez
dans quelques instants nous expliquer en
quoi le café de la plage est impliqué
dans ce dispositif mais tout d'abord je
vais m'adresser à vous tirer est ce que
pourrait nous rappeler déjà les grands
principes les grandes missions en fait
dit live lors il ait donc c'est un
dispositif que vous l'avez dit qui a été
inaugurée en 92 par le réseau du cri par
l'ensemble des salles qui constituent ce
réseau pour promouvoir le potentiel
artistique présence sur le territoire
des yvelines sous toutes ses formes ce
soit le rock la chanson le jazz électro
le rap et l'idée c'est de sélectionner
un certain nombre d'artistes tous les
ans ou tous les deux ans suivant les
périodes pour les accompagner justement
vers un développement de carrière qui
les amène pour certains avoir une
carrière professionnelle à vif de la
musique et à voir aussi pour certains
une carrière qui dépasse les frontières
des yvelines de la france voire même
plus enfin comment certains aujourd'hui
sont reconnus sur la sienne sur la scène
nationale alors peut-être je vous
l'avais dit ce sont des candidatures si
l'appel à un appel à candidature au
départ donc vous les sélectionner c'est
un accompagnement professionnel vous
leur proposez finalement à la fois un
accompagnement technique artistique
scénique et puis la mise en relation
aussi avec raisons
professionnelles en fait il ya deux
volets un volet de promotion donc l'idée
c'est de les faire jouer sur dans notre
réseau de salles c'est aussi de les
exporter vers les diffuseurs au niveau
ile-de-france et nationales de les
valoriser à travers des compilations cdd
choqué etc mais aussi un côté formation
très important l'idée c'est de leur
faire découvrir l'envers du décor du
métier d'artiste à travers tout ce qui
organise les structures le monde de la
musique et les aider à mieux appréhender
tout cet univers assez complexe
d'ailleurs en étant le mieux à mes
larmes est possible donc voilà donc cédé
des formations ponctuelles qui porte sur
ce qu'on va pas le chant administrative
du milieu du spectacle aussi artistique
à travers des résidences puisqu'ils ont
la possibilité à travers ce dispositif
de passer plusieurs jours dans des
salles de concerts pouvoir travailler
leur spectacle revient avec les attentes
ce qui est très important c'est que tout
ce dispositif existe que parce qu'il ya
des salles qui se mobilisent pour le
faire vivre alors du coup donc cette
année vous fêtez pour 20 en 20 ans de ce
dispositif et à cette occasion vous
organisé quatre concerts dans quatre
salles partenaires
le premier aura lieu demain demain soir
donc c'est à saint germain à la clé et
se clôturera dimanche au café de la
plage alors peut-être est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de ces groupes que
vous avez sélectionné qui sont il est ce
que c'est les groupes justement de cette
année non voilà justement on est
vraiment sûr
lui mettre en avant le côté mémoire de
ce dispositif et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
groupes qui ont fait vivre la ville ya
quinze ou vingt ans et qui se reforment
spécialement pour l'occasion et qui
viennent nous rejoindre sur ce temps de
festivités dont on a des 30 ils vont le
faire après sa droite dure est-ce que ça
produira mais on est là dans un moment
de célébration il ya une dimension
festive qu'on assume complètement donc à
la fois des groupes reconnus qui ont ils
sont un peu peut-être locomotive sur
l'événement mais aussi beaucoup d' là
comme les blérots de ravel par exemple
qu'ils vont jouer le stress pintos à
rambouillet vendredi mais l'idée c'est
vraiment de faire appel à toute la
diversité de ces groupes qui font yves
life qui ont fait vivre live et beaucoup
ont joué le jeu et ont remonté leur
groupe exprès pour l'événement et pour
nous ça nous fait vraiment très plaisir
du côté de maurepas au café de la plage
ip est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
dimanche donc le concert est à 15 heures
cinq groupes vont monter sur scène qui
sont ils ont trois formations justement
mais sinon là les anciens des anciens
dont des treize anciens on va commencer
avec sa bande qui était d'ailleurs cassé
un ongle et matic sa première sélection
le premier en 92 un groupe de reggae
reggae roots donc qui étaient autour
d'achères après on va continuer avec mam
sic a peu qui était sur une règle de
sélection plus récentes en 2009 qui sont
de huy qui font plutôt du jazz un peu
world ils appellent ça du jazz nomades
en tout cas c'est
bien sa violoncelliste et un
percussionniste donc voilà c'est très
varié très très riche on va continuer
avec nassara qui est pratique du reggae
soukouss world qui viennent de ben
qu'ils sont blancs locales à bienne
avait connu très apprécié c'est une
information également après on continue
avec pad à waco qui sont plus tôt
fou qui sont suivis à maurepas sédé marc
payen démord pas et voilà depuis très
longtemps ils sont suivis par les
studios le cobalt et par un café de la
plage ils ont été vives live sur l'année
2006 2007 et vie pratique funk groovy et
que les anneaux matteau paix maintenant
un peu plus d'électro donc très riche
très variés aussi et on va finir le
grand final ça se racler l'attitude
qu'ils sont très attendues de saint
germain en laye qui faisait un grand
écart entre le rock et le hip hop connu
un beau parcours qui sont sortis des
frontières largement qui ont été repérés
sur le printemps de bourges en 2008 et
qui sont en ce moment même au café de la
plage en résidence retraite c'était al
anon qu'il prépare finalement le concert
de dimanche pourrait vraiment prêt et
résidences ongola vous les accompagnez à
nouveau sur sur la partie quoi ceni
sonique uniquement à la remise en place
du répertoire ils ont un peu répété
avant on se répète mais il avait besoin
de s'accaparer et de reprendre la main
sur une scène donc voilà qui sont là
pendant deux jours c'était hier et
aujourd'hui et demain à nassara pendant
deux jours qui avait besoin de remonter
sur une scène je vous propose qu'on
regarde un extrait une compilation de
tous ces groupes
l'eau
la dre
mais comment
j'ai peint
comme ça
avec toi
jeumont
donc ça sera une scène avec l'éthique
alors on l'a entendu seul groupe qu'on a
pas pu voir leur n'extrait c'est island
puisque comme vous le disiez il date de
en tout cas les les moments device et en
d'image de 92 alors moi malgré tout donc
là c'est groupe comment vous les avez
fait venir est ce que il a fallu les
convaincre
quel message vous leur avez donné alors
il ya eu un espèce l'appel parmi des
gens qui sont encore dans le réseau
notamment voilà pour les groupes qui
étaient en formation il ya des gens qui
sont devenus des acteurs du réseau soit
encore musiciens soient qui travaillent
dans les salles ou bénévole ou en tout
cas proche des salles donc ça n'a pas
été si compliqué que ça aucun n'était
vraiment très éloigné de la musique
directement il a fallu redonner une
petite impulsion petite étincelle il ya
des gens qui sont là qui font vivre au
jour le jour les salles qui ont des
équipements qu'ils ont des formats à
proposer leurs navires et on avait des
facilités à proposer donc ça a été
plutôt facile de susciter l'envié alors
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce que ça vous
apporte dans le café de la plage je
parle de participer aux vingt ans d'une
part il ya le côté cadeaux qui dit
anniversaire dit cadeau donc c'est un
cadeau interne au réseau pour les
adhérents voilà on est plus que
partenaire on est vraiment actif dans le
réseau pour les publics qui suivent
c'est beaucoup c'est groupe coups qui
ont suivi ces groupes là même il ya
encore il y avait un temps où il ya
moins longtemps pour les bénévoles pour
les proches des salles pour les gens qui
apprécient encore de sortir en café
concert ou dans cette petite salle et
d'une autre part c'est aussi une manière
de démontrer notre activisme pour être
dans un réseau sont en être acteur
s'emparer des formats ont créé à
l'initiative c'était clairement se
positionner devant on est là pour le
réseau et on peut accueillir cinq
groupes sur un dimanche sur un format
peut-être pas aisée mais on a très envie
avec ça se fasse on peut rappeler aussi
que le café de la plage a été rénové
réel édité l'année dernière et
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez deux salles
donc ce qui va aussi faciliter justement
la présence de ces cinq groupes sur sur
une après midi parce qu'à fini jusqu'à
21h c'est ça 15h et 15h20 heure 5h05
groupe chacun joue une petite heure et
on va jouer en alternance dans la grande
salle et la petite salle ok bon alors à
l'occasion aussi de ses 20 ans du coup
ressort un magazine que vous avez dirigé
donc ses 78 tours alors là c'est une
édition un peu spéciale j'en ai
up l'exclusivité ici voilà j'ai pas si
vous voyez bien donc ce magazine reprend
finalement retrace les vingt ans 10 live
les moments forts une interview de d'un
groupe par année globalement voilà tout
ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver et donc ce
journal sera mise à disposition dont
chacune des salles partenaires donc pour
ceux qui souhaitent
le regarde et voilà et puis par ailleurs
il va il s'intéresse aussi à l'or c'est
un autre domaine on initie palais
l'attiré donc je m'adresse à vous je dis
donc demain en ouverture du premier
concert vous organisés en fait une
conférence de presse sur le thème vote
ont plus de musique dans les villes
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est que
cette démarche
on va dire c'est un leitmotiv depuis 20
ans il travaille dur raison du christ et
d'accompagner les collectivités et les
élus sur la nécessaire adaptation des
politiques publiques ou réalité de la
musique d'aujourd'hui
cette structure radiale la question des
structures des équipements et la
question des commandes accompagne
l'apprentissage de la musique tels qui
s'opèrent aujourd'hui comme on permet à
toute la masse de plus en plus
importante des musiques et des groupes
dits amateurs de s'exprimer sur scène
tout un tas de jeux qui sont pas
forcément qui n'a pas qu'il amène pas
forcément à des réalités en tout cas des
solutions partout sur le territoire des
yvelines donc il ya cette question
effectivement de territoires qui seront
aussi pas forcément équipés en scène
adaptée en suivant de répétition ça
quand on est plutôt bien dotées mélo
territoire où c'est plus complexe voilà
donc notre travail c'est de 25 villes
basques ont dit on dit souvent c'est que
les deux plus grandes communes des
yvelines c'est à dire versailles se
retrouvent il n'y a pas d'équipements
dédiés pour les musiques actuelles donc
ça fait parti d'un combat j'irai une
posture qu'on a depuis 20 ans donc on
fait beaucoup c'est une action
pédagogique nous qui se veut plutôt
explicative et qui invite les citoyens
les mélomanes les musiciens à s'y
intéresser voter a voté par un site
internet voilà où on peut voter
effectivement et adhérer donc à 7 à ce
projet ce projet sachant que notre
démarche a consisté à rencontrer tous
les candidats qui le serait en tout cas
des municipales pour expliquer un peu en
quoi ce projet d'adaptation et de
positionner la musique comme un des
enjeux des politiques municipales peut
être intéressant et une vraie
opportunité en tout cas merci à tous les
deux d'être venu sur le plateau du
kiosque donc on rappelle la date de
dimanche donc à 15 heures au café de la
plage donc pour un concert des vingt ans
delight cinq groupes seront présents
n'hésitez pas à vous y rendre à réserver
toutes les coordonnées se sont affichées
merci beaucoup à tous les deux alors
maintenant nous passons au théâtre parce
que dans le cadre du plan de lutte
contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité la compagnie déclic théâtre a
créé welcome à bord alors c'est un
spectacle présenté aux collégiens ou
clichés et idées reçues provoc mais
surtout ont pour but d'éveiller les
consciences image d'elle de jonathan
willeman pas nous vous souhaitons un
agréable voyage à bord du conformer à
welcome à bord du confort bien la
traversée desservira l'archipel des
cloisons où se trouvent les îles et ben
venus des d'aaron des crevards ou encore
des dollars que vous soyez noir blanc
jeune riche ou pauvre chacun y trouvera
ainsi sa place enfin il s'agit surtout
de ce que la compagnie déclic théâtre
veut dénoncer avec humour grâce à cet
outil théâtrale welcome abord spectacle
pour les scolaires créer en 2012 par
quatre comédiens de la compagnie
s'inscrit dans le cadre du plan de lutte
contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité c'était vraiment pour pour
répondre à une demande par rapport aux
établissements scolaires du coup on a
été observée dans plusieurs écoles a
récupéré pas mal de deux témoignent à la
fois d'élèves de professeurs et puis
ensuite on sait on s'est vraiment mis
tous les quatre et on s'est mis à écrire
à réunir un peu tous les clichés qu'on
avait amassé cabiten aussi la qualité et
non consensuelle
j'aurais dû m'en douter j'avais trouvé
un tee shirt rose et des gags à l'eau
salée si
la vie ce matin c'est
subjectif c'est sa c2 d'éveiller les
consciences et de se dire que si on a
des discussions sur la discrimination le
sexisme enfin tôt peut-être qu'on
retarde un petit peu la pression de la
société cas société aura sur sur les
gens présenté aujourd'hui aux élèves du
collège youri-gagarine de trappes le
spectacle est suivi d'un débat avec un
juriste une méthode pour laisser
s'exprimer les clichés et les préjugés
j'essaye après de ramener un spectacle
au sujet des discriminations de devoirs
avec eux des définitions importante des
mots stéréotypes des clichés de leur
faire comprendre un peu les mécanismes
de mise en place de des discriminations
comment on peut arriver soit mais m ou
bien victimes ou bien auteur d'une
discrimination j'ai appris qu'il faut
pas discriminer les gens ci interdit par
la loi
il faut avoir un minimum de respect par
exemple j'ai un copain des fois je le
traite a fait de grosses des traités sur
le physique mais pour rigoler mais il
n'aimait pas trop alors je pense que je
vais arrêter comme ça les gens quand ils
vont traiter les auteurs pourraient
gérer la discrimination tout ça
le message semble être bien passé le
spectacle se produira dans d'autres
lieux à la demande des établissements
scolaires
retrouvons sans plus attendre nicolas
jaar est pour sa chronique dans le
casque
violoncelliste elle navigue en terre
poétique à la croisée des arts la maison
de la poésie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lui a donné
carte blanche pour six soirées
intitulées les jeudis de bérénice dont
la première aura lieu le 9 janvier voici
bérénice cathala dans le kiosque
j'ai eu l'occasion de jouer en tant que
violoncelliste et de mettre en musique
de la poésie et à la demande de jacques
fournier directeur de la maison de la
poésie et je lui ai confié
ce plaisir et cette passion que j'ai à
mélanger les arts pour l'instant il m'a
donné cette carte blanche pour les
jeudis de bérénice mais en étant en se
cantonnant vraiment poésie et musique
rappel un sud
où
les goélands monte avec leurs sifflets
jeudi de bérénice ça sera le deuxième
jeudi de chaque mois à 20h30 et ça pour
l'instant on a établi
de janvier à juin 2014 et l'idée c'est
de faire rencontrer
des poètes de faire de valoriser de
jeunes poètes et les mettre en contact
avec des musiciens
le style doit être très variées
tant au niveau musical qu'au niveau
instrumental et surtout ce que j'aime
dans ces rencontres c'est qu'il y ait
beaucoup de partis pris voilà ce soit
très typé
layadi d'affaires écoles des bagnards
donc ils vont retourner paul et sur le
cheminement thomas d'helmand les bateaux
se balance comme le berceau
noval de son visage au crépuscule
s'affrontent avec le tien juste derrière
la porte vitrée
ces zones avaient
l'air et de café et cordages ni le
dernier bouton d'or sur le but on a
mature ndumu label h à la halle et
rieuse ou la deutsche à l
étude et il connaît pas ou c'est le
poète qui doit qui lit ses textes
ou alors il y aura un comédien ce que
j'aime dans ce dans ces rencontres c'est
ce défi qui doivent se lancer d'aller au
delà de ce qu'ils ont l'habitude de
faire simplement décrire ou simplement
de jouer c'est vraiment une rencontre où
chacun doit se dépasser dans son dans
son habitude de pratique instrumentale
ou de poètes le simple fait déjà pour le
poète de lire c'est carrément un autre
métier et en même temps ça lui permet
d'avoir un autre regard sur ce qu'il a
écrit et au niveau musical c'est de
s'imprégner dans un univers de poésie
sont pas forcément poète
avec l'arrivée de
l'ipad à égaler john kyffy la une sur
malouda c'est
là
regarder encore et encore l'air chaud
il ya toujours une partie de mise en
scène qui peut être très épuré mais
cette mise en scène doit refléter dans
ce que j'aimerais
l'état d'esprit dans lequel se trouvait
le poète au moment il a écrit à ce
qu'elle a écrit ça sera une soirée d'une
heure donc c'est assez court pourra y
avoir de l'improvisation musicale bateau
ce plan bien que je ne connais pas les
noms on commence quand même d'accord que
but que c'est normal et blood malev le
flanc dans le sien qu'on ai marre je
n'ai pas encore lu hier une
semaine maze avoir lieu et que racontent
les étoiles quand il est listé comme
monter les escaliers comme ceux de nice
cannes l'univers d' anna lisa comes ça
s'appelle hors terre ferme et ce texte
sera mis en musique par jean pierre la
nesque et percussionniste c'est arrivé à
un moment donné de la vie d'anna lisa où
elle est partie d'italie puisqu'elle est
italienne c'est un texte donc italien
elle est partie de son pays pour
presque une migration vers la france et
avec pas mal de déchirures de coupure
dans sa vie et
et voilà la description de tout un
univers de bretagne
quoi de la cuisine le barrage embarras
du
ça fait deux mois qu'ils nous
du coup
ce conte
la piste d'élan gosling à la soa global
am chaud
il va y avoir une double lecture
italiens français ils m'ont demandé de
lire les poèmes en français je ne suis
pas comédienne mais
il y a une relation particulière entre
les a et moi on a une entente très
simple il me semble avoir déjà traversé
saison une fois
et pendant qu'ils emportent l'addition
de des cafés savoie a lu
sur le visage
et après les jeudis de bérénice on
retourne au mercredi d'aurélia
et oui nous sommes bien mercredi c'est
donc l'heure des sorties ciné au micro
d' elodie moines
je pense m ennuyer m'a pas du tout ça
m'a beaucoup plu moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
c'est très très drôle très caustique
sympa les acteurs sont formidables c'est
un set un bon moment très bien mais
je m'attendais à mieux quand même il
était vraiment cool comme le 1 mais la
fin est un peu décevante ou plutôt bien
plutôt bien on attend le trot avec
impatience enfin le début était un peu
un peu long mais dès l'apparition du
dragon c'est tout un symbole que du bien
mais j'aurais vu les mecs et une fin
même provisoire une fin quand même sauf
si un petit peu les ché
c'est comme ça
en attente c'était vraiment super je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça dure aussi
longtemps c'était
c'était très complet et j'ai vraiment
adoré sens super spectacle je pense que
c'est encore mieux en 3d mais c'est un
super spectacle vraiment
alors comme vous le savez déjà sûrement
cinéphiles c'est aussi l'occasion
d'écouter un professionnel nous donner
son coup de coeur et cette semaine c'est
au tour de guet pino responsable du
grenier à sel à trappes dans les côtes
bonjour cette semaine je vais vous
parler de mon coup de coeur mon coup de
coeur c'est les garçons et guillaume à
table c'est un film réalisé par
guillaume gallienne adapté d'un one man
show autobiographique de guillaume
gallienne joué par guillaume gallienne
dont vous l'avez compris c'est lui qui
fait quasiment tous dans le film c'est
l'histoire d'un come c'est le coming out
d'un terreau sexuelle de guillaume
gallienne
c'est très drôle guillaume gallienne il
est surtout connu pour ses seconds rôles
notamment dans le dernier astérix mais
aussi pour ses sketchs qui faisait sur
canal+ de 2008 à 2010 à s'appeler les
bonus de guillaume
le film a été ovationnée lors de la
quinzaine des réalisateurs à cannes au
mois de mai et depuis il ne cesse de
séduire les spectateurs et les
professionnels à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui il a déjà sorti bien sûr
il a déjà fait plus d'un million de
spectateurs et
c'est le bouche à oreille surtout qui
marche beaucoup beaucoup pour ce film
donc c'est un film qui plaît énormément
nous vous proposons au grenier à sel en
première partie un court métrage comme à
notre habitude et cette semaine le court
métrage sera bleu blood & christmas 2
c'est l'histoire d'un sapin de noël
tueur qui attaquent la ville c'est aussi
une petite comédie déjantée avec
frédérique bel c'est aussi très drôle ça
va très bien avec avec le film qui suit
je vous propose à présent quelques idées
de sorties pour ces prochains jours
alors tout d'abord il est possible
d'assister à un spectacle d'une troupe
d'artistes venus de singapour il s'agit
du circle du cirque bleu du vietnam donc
ce sera samedi 14 décembre à 20h30 à la
ferme du manet si vous avez envie de
magie et de féerie un spectacle musical
peter pan sera proposée samedi et
dimanche au théâtre de l'espace coluche
à plaisir et enfin mardi 17 descend donc
mardi prochain à 20h30 au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines se donnera le
célèbre opéra de mozart la flûte
enchantée revisité par peter brook un
succès international depuis sa création
voilà notre édition est à présent
terminée je vous retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine mercredi prochain à
18h30 en direct d'ici là profitez de la
richesse culturelle de notre territoire
à bientôt